[Музика]
привіт усім
мене звати Анна. Я вчитель англійської мови,
тому сьогодні в 9 класі ми
продовжимо вивчати тему
молодіжної культури, про яку ми вже говорили,
і сьогодні ми
зосередимося на  одна з них
модна, тож давайте подивимося на
слайд і подивіться на велику сумку,
яку ви можете побачити тут, щоб на цій сумці було
багато різних модних брендів,
ви знаєте когось із них, тож давайте
подивимося на  Перше, що ми можемо розпізнати,
це манго, який насправді є брендом масового ринку, а
будь-які інші, які ми можемо
побачити, зразки, які більше схожі на розкішний
один день, цей бренд спортивного одягу добре,
що ще ми можемо побачити тут
Gucci і наші гроші - це
розкіш  бренди також, тож давайте
подивимося на деякі інші бренди, тут ми
побачимо Tom Ford Puma, а також, які
ще бренди ви добре знаєте, ви складаєте
інший список модних брендів, які вам
особисто подобаються чи не подобаються, а тепер
давайте подивимося  на б
Знову нашим завданням буде зіставити
назви відомих модних брендів з
ефектами про них, тож давайте подивимося
на назви бренду, перш за все,
так номер один dr.  Мартенс два чоботи
Versace три Levis для Adidas номер
п'ять, його Nike шість - це chanel, а номер
сім - для кросівок converse, а
тепер давайте подивимося на
описи цих брендів найбіліші
художники, але один не був опусом другого
бренду ви дорослий Ослер  почав виготовляти
взуття після світової війни перший у 1924
році другий вогонь
вони називають chucks на честь
баскетболіста Чака Тейлора бачать, що він
відомий косметикою парфумів номер п'ять
і є засновницею міс Коко Ді, вони мають
унікальну м'яку верхню форму та
жовті шви II  Містер.  Штраус хотів
зробити міцні штани для неповнолітніх, щоб
носити F, італійський бренд, відомий
сукнями, парфумерією та аксесуарами, і
останній факт, що назва компанії
походить від грецької богині перемоги,
тому давайте ще раз поглянемо на бренди
і давайте  зіставте їх із
визначеннями, щоб чоботи одного лікаря Мон Мартіна
ви вже впізнали, який
факт стосується цих черевиків, це D,
звичайно, вони мають унікальну амортизаційну
підошву, тому їх легко впізнати
наступний бренд, наступний бренд Versace, то
що  Як ви думаєте, це був би
опис тут, подивіться ще раз,
і так, звичайно, це F, це
італійський модний бренд Levis, ви, напевно,
знаєте цей бренд за джинсами, які вони виготовляють,
і насправді факт про них – це e
господиня довіряє жінкам як
Засновник бренду вирішив створити
штани для людей, щоб люди могли носити їх на роботу,
інший Adidas, тому тут ми
маємо ім'я засновника
компанії для дорослих Dust ler.
наступний
Nike, як ти думаєш, що це
насправді ім'я грецької богині,
тож цей факт G наступний - Шанель, так що
всі знають Шанель, усі знають
Коко Шанель, і так, факт про цей
модний бренд - C і останній
конверс  кросівки, тож тут у нас точно
є B, тому кросівки
американською англійською також називаються chucks,
добре, так що з тобою як модником
чи, можливо, ти не модник, то
як мода впливає на наше життя, це
питання для тебе, щоб подумати над іншим
питанням  Ви маєте розглянути, чи
є у вас своя мода чи ви стежите
за натовпом, чи намагаєтеся ви створити свій власний
стиль, подумайте про це та інше
питання, якщо вам байдуже, що люди
думають про вас, який одяг ви б
одягли, тому я думаю  ваші відповіді будуть
дуже цікавими, тому ви можете їх
записати або просто подумати,
а тепер ми переходимо до іншого завдання, нам
потрібно зіставити слова з
визначеннями, з якими всі ці слова
пов’язані  тема моди
давайте подивимося на унікальність
три слідувати чотири наряди п'ять scruffa li6
витрачати
сім статуй вісім дивно дев'ять
upside and tan boutique
ви, ймовірно, вже знаєте деякі з цих
слів, і тепер наше завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб зіставити
ці слова з визначеннями
праворуч a тут ми маємо набір одягу,
часто з аксесуарами B, щоб рухатися в
напрямку або йти за чимось C
позиція відносно престижу інших,
якщо наступним є D
перевага ситуації e дуже дивна
та незвичайна  несподіваний чи неприродний F
ввічливість, честь і турбота, виявлені до
когось чи чогось, що вважаються
важливими G єдиний існуючий
у своєму роді незвичайний чи особливий H невеликий
магазин, який продає модний одяг,
взуття, прикраси тощо I хтось, хто витрачає
гроші чи витратив
її  запам’ятайте слово
марнотратство з одного з наших попередніх
уроків, а Джея — останній у вигляді,
який виглядає неохайно і трохи брудно, тож
давайте подивимося на t  він слів ще
раз, тож яке, на вашу думку, було б
правильним визначенням для слова повага,
подивіться
ще раз на визначення праворуч, і так, це f, тож
повага має синонім ввічливості, тому ми
збігаємо визначення F з номером один на
другий  слово є унікальним українською мовою, яке
звучить як una colony, тож як ви
думаєте, що може бути визначенням фірмової
назви в барометрах лава una colony
це щось дуже особливе,
щось своєрідне,
тому визначення тут буде G,
оскільки існує єдине в одному  наступне слово -
слідувати, тому, коли ми говоримо про те, як
слідувати модним тенденціям, ми насправді
розглядаємо їх використання або рухаємося в
напрямку модних тенденцій, все
правильно,
наступне слово - це вбрання, це
насправді набір одягу, який ви вирішили
носити, тому визначення  тут буде
номер п'ятий потертості, тож це
спосіб носити найближче, і вони можуть виглядати
неохайними, а це означатиме, що вони
насправді не чисті, настільки неохайні або трохи
брудні.  право наступний розтратник номер шість,
тож це людина, яка любить
витрачати гроші занадто багато на одяг, тому
тут у нас буде визначення я ношу
слово марнотратник, яке ви вже знаєте,
статуї номер сім, як ви можете
описати слово статуї, у якому ви, ймовірно,
знаєте його  українська мова, тож як
ми просто опишемо її іншими словами із
синонімами тут, нам знадобиться визначення
дивіться, так це позиція
щодо інших добре номер вісім дивно, тому
коли ми говоримо про щось дивне, ми маємо на
увазі, що це щось дивне для
вас
і тут  нам потрібно поєднати визначення II
дуже дивне і незвичайне несподіване
наступне, тому це D
перевага ситуації, тому коли
щось добре в користі, а
останній батик, це тип магазину,
і це досить легко зрозуміти  що
тут у нас є визначення H для цього слова
добре, тепер, коли ми знаємо ці слова,
ми готові побачити їх у тексті, і
тепер нашим завданням буде прочитати текст
і послухати його  d потім ми
заповнимо прогалини, де слова незвичайна
мода викликають у вас більше поваги.
Дослідники з Гарвардської
школи бізнесу кажуть, що люди, які не хочуть
нормальної моди, є більш шанованими
аспірантка Сільвія Беллезза в двох
професорах дослідили, як ми сприймаємо
соціальне та
Вони виявили,
що чим більше незнайомі люди одягаються, тим
вільніше вони отримують. Учасники
дослідження сказали, що вважали, що люди, які
займаються модою, носять більше дудки, а не
погано думають про когось, хто одягнений шість років, багато
людей вважають, що одягатися - це  На
знак впевненості Місба Лотса сказав, що якщо
ви готові відхилитися, то
сім експериментів малета провели, щоб
перевірити, як люди реагують на невідповідність,
люди одягнені по-різному на дорогу
восьмерку в Мілані, одна група була
одягнена в спортивний одяг, а інша в
дорогу 9 продавці-консультанти  вважали,
що ті, що в спортивному спорядженні, були
більшими 10 в іншому тесті студенти
оцінили u  Професор nshaven у
сорочці над професором у костюмі
Бледсо каже, що генеральні директори знаменитостей, які
одягаються, можливо, змінили нашу думку,
прикладами цього є толстовки генерального директора Facebook Марка
Цукерберга та покійні
джинси та кросівки Стіва Джобса, які він
носив.  подивіться на перше
речення тексту з першим пробілом,
щоб дослідники з Гарвардської
школи бізнесу сказали, що люди, які не так,
що люди роблять з модою, коли вони
насправді носять модний одяг,
стильний одяг, щоб вони дотримувалися нормальної
моди, тому номер один слідував  другий
розрив вони відповідають, розуміючи, як ми дивимося на
соціальне щось, тож як ви думаєте,
що слово для цього розриву має бути в порядку,
тут нам потрібно слово статуї, давайте рухатися
вперед, вони виявили, що чим
дивніше люди одягаються, тим більше
чогось вони отримують, тож що може  люди
відчувають себе, коли одягаються незвично, тому вони
насправді завойовують повагу, це досить
дивно, але, як ви бачите,
згідно з дослідженням, це настільки
учасник  У дослідженні ts сказали, що
вони думали, що люди з певною
модою носять більше чогось, тому прогалини чотири
і п’ять, тому ми говоримо про дивну
моду, тому, безумовно, у номері чотири
нам знадобиться слово дивно, а
ми більше того, що  для числа п'ять давайте
дамо йому річ, і так, тут ми будемо
використовувати слово унікальний, тобто єдиний у своєму роді,
а не думати, що був погано про когось
номер шість одягнений, то як можна одягнути людину,
яка провокує інших людей
думати погано  з них, тож тут нам
знадобиться слово пошарпаний, звичайно, добре, і
давайте перейдемо до числа сім у цьому
абзаці, якщо ви готові відхилитися,
це як би бути іншим,
ось деякі хороші речі, деякі
переваги, тож як ми називаємо слово
переваги  як синонім, який ми
щойно бачили на попередньому слайді, так
, це слово «виворіт», давайте перейдемо до
проміжки номер вісім людей, одягнених по-
різному за дорогу суму в
мільйони, звичайно, ми маємо на увазі магазини, але якщо
ми говоримо про маленькі дорогі
магазини ми будемо використовувати слово бутіки проміжок
номер дев'ять, одна група була спортивною близькою,
а інша була одягнена в дороге,
що тут може бути, тож ми говоримо про
комплекти одягу, і ми будемо використовувати слово "
наряди добре" і проміжок номер десять, як
подумали продавці  ті, хто в
спортивному спорядженні, ми більші, у
нас залишилося лише одне слово, яке є
марнотратником, але тут у нас є
трохи інший варіант цього слова,
який витрачає добре, тепер, коли ми
закінчили заповнювати слова
текст, давайте перевіримо, як ви розумієте
текст і що саме ви запам’ятали з
нього, тому наше завдання зараз полягає в тому, щоб з’ясувати,
правдиві чи хибні наступні речення,
давайте подивимося на перше,
яке
дослідники з Оксфордського університету
провели дослідження про моду, тому  чи це
правда чи правильні лише факти, згадані в цьому
реченні, тож тут ми розуміємо,
що це неправда, що був інший
університет, і ваше завдання –
з’ясувати, який один номер два люди думали
ті, хто одягався дивно, були унікальними, чи
це правда так, звісно, номер тр
дослідження прийшло до висновку, що од
гатися є ознакою впевненості, що вд
гатися в першу чергу, одягатися, оз
ачає не носити стильний одяг чи не
осити дуже  офіційний одяг,
щоб одягатися просто, щоб бути більш повсякденним,
так чи правда, що це ознака
впевненості, коли людина носить
одяг, який не надто офіційний, так,
це насправді правда, оскільки ви можете побачити
номер чотири, один експеримент, подивіться на
сприйняття продавця  у дині, тож
вони перевіряють, як продавці-консультанти реагували
на людей, які носять різний
одяг, так, це правда, п'ятий факт,
що група людей у спортивному одязі вв
жалася більшими витрачаючими, тож як
родавці-консультанти сприймали таких лю
ей людей, які носять спортивний од
г  одяг, це правда чи неправда
так, це правда так, це правда, студенти номер шість
оцінили професора в костюмі вище,
ніж у футболці,
це правда.  відношення студентів до
професора в офіційному костюмі офіційний
одяг краще, ніж до того, хто
одягнений лише у футболку та джинси, що
ви пам'ятаєте з тексту, це правда
чи неправда, звичайно, це
неправда студенти відреагували краще  до
професора, який насправді одягався так,
щоб людина, яка не носила офіційного
одягу, був офіційний костюм і номер сім
тут у статті говориться, що генеральні директори не повинні
носити толстовки, джинси і кросівки,
це правда чи неправда, що ви думаєте, з
чого ви пам'ятаєте  у тексті
було згадано, що насправді було зазначено,
що вони повинні носити толстовки, і
насправді це не проблема для SEO-спеціалістів і
для менеджерів бренду та компаній
трохи одягатися, що, навпаки,
насправді допомагає їм бути більш дружніми
до людей, з якими вони працюють  з окей, тепер,
коли ми закінчили читати і ми
вже впоралися зі словами до
пропусків у тегах,
і ми вже перевірили, наскільки добре ви
розумієте текст і що таке
чоловіки  настав час зробити
крихітний знімок Grammer, подивіться ось у нас
є слайд, який ви могли побачити на одному
з попередніх уроків, тож комбінації
, за якими слідують герундії, ви
пам’ятаєте деякі з них. Я сподіваюся, що ви
пам’ятаєте всі  їх насправді, так що
подивіться на речення sandy is scared of
flying і тут ми маємо структуру
прикметників + прийменник scared - це
прикметник слово off - це
прийменник наступний приклад Нік турбується про
здачу іспиту, і тут ми маємо
прикметник +  прийменник прикметник
тривожний прийменник about then they
all супроводжується ing, як ви можете бачити це
підкреслено в наступному слові інший
приклад, його зацікавлення стати
сноубордистом був добре відомий тут у нас
є іменник інтерес + прийменник у
них слідує герундій слово  Стати
з ing ending tomas історія про
побаченого ведмедя грізлі була дійсно захоплюючою, і
тут ми також маємо
історію про прийменник, за яким
слідує герундій wh  я бачу з
ing ok тепер, коли ми згадали
деяку інформацію, яку ми
вже вивчили, тож тепер давайте перейдемо до
практики, наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб вибрати
правильний пункт, тож подивіться тут, у нас є
вісім речень, у яких наше завдання
досить просто, просто виберіть, яке слово
є правильним, тому подивіться на
перше речення Агата запросила мене
витратити або провести літо в будинку її
родини в Коста-Ріці.
Зазвичай, коли у нас є особа, на яку
ми посилалися, ми використовуємо інфінітив, тому
тут ми повинні сказати, що запросив мене провести
все добре, номер два. Я не вірив
історії про Каміллу про те, що вона знайшла або
знайшла гарну сукню на спині в парку  то чи
можете ви повірити в це, чи можете ви дійсно
добре використовувати граматичну структуру, тож давайте
подивимося на історію про тут у нас є іменник
story та прийменник about is it
за яким слід ing is it слід
інфінітив, який становить два плюс дієслово it
definitivno ha  Розповідь про те, що ми
знайшли номер три, жахлива
погода змусила нас змінити, змінивши наші
плани, тут знову у нас є об'єкт, за яким
має слідувати інфінітив, і
саме змінити жахливу погоду
змусила нас змінити наші плани номер
чотири  Діана боялася плавати
або плавати в океані з тих пір, як
подивилася фільм «Щелепи добре», давайте
подивимося на слова, які йдуть одне за
одним, страшно, тут у нас є
прикметник і прийменник прийменник
scared прийменник це має
слідувати  за герундієм за ним має
слідувати ing, тож правильний спосіб сказати, що
це має бути Діана злякалася
плавати номер п'ять я не знаю, як
ти змусила мого сина з'їсти чи їсти його
брокколі, він ненавидить овочі, тож
які  чи будемо ми використовувати тут, ви вже знаєте,
що один так однозначно має бути
інфінітивом я не знаю, як ви змусили мого
сина з'їсти брокколі наступний
номер шість я їздив з банджі або стрибком з
банджі, коли я був у
Нью  Зеландія це було чудово, тож ми ходимо
стрибнути з банджі або ми ходимо
стрибками з банджі зазвичай разом зі спортивними
вправами з фізичними навантаженнями, коли
ми використовуємо дієслово go we follow ми використовуємо
герундій, щоб слідувати за цим словом, тому я пішов
банджі-джампінг наступне  номер
сім Саллі
у вільний час любить ходити до вітрин чи вітрин,
вона зазвичай нічого не купує, просто
любить жити, тому вона любить ходити у
вітрини чи вітрини,
це досить легко здогадатися, що ви вже маєте
я чув правило про це під номером
шість, тож у чому це має бути
впевненим, щоб шопінг у вітринах Саллі любив
ходити за вітринами, а
останній номер восьмий, чому
він вибрав або вирішив купити цей
дивний одяг, завжди був мені незрозумілим
тому причини, чому тут у нас є іменник +
прийменник, за цією структурою має
слідувати ing, тому ми скажемо, чому він
вибрав причини вибору, чому він вирішив
купити цей дивний одяг,
ми завжди незрозумілі для мене добре, це все
з нашою вправою це все з нашою
граматичною практикою, і тепер настав час для
вашого домашнього завдання для наступного уроку,
тож що нам потрібно зробити, перш за все,
вивчити слова з сьогоднішнього уроку, ось
вони до правильної поваги
uniq follow outfit scruff elite  розкіш,
статуї, дивний видобуток, і ще одне
завдання для вас — скласти сім речень
із цими словами
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож це ваше домашнє завдання на
наступний урок, дякую за
увагу і до зустрічі наступного разу
[Музика]